[Music plays]
>>Presenter: It's my pleasure to welcome,
it's our pleasure I guess, at Google, to welcome
the co creators of "Husbands", Brad Bell and
Jane Espenson who are going to talk about
"Inventing Television: How Husbands Fully
Realizes the Promise."
Please join me in welcoming Brad and Jane.
[Applause]
>>Jane Espenson: I guess we should say a little
bit who we are and then we can talk about
why we're inventing television.
>>Brad Bell: Oh, okay.
>>Jane Espenson: I'm Jane Espenson, I'm one
of the creators of "Husbands" which is, we're
gonna show you a couple episodes of it and
talk about it and how it is inventing television.
>>Brad Bell: Truly.
Oh, you wait.
>>Jane Espenson: I have, I come at this from
the TV side.
I have a 20 year TV career, I've written for
"Buffy the Vampire Slayer" and "Battle Star
Galactica" and "Game of Thrones" and "Once
Upon a Time" which check it out, ABC, Sunday
night.
>>Brad Bell: If you've watched TV you've seen
something by her.
>>Jane Espenson: If you've watched, particularly
if you've watched geeky, sci-fi TV you've
definitely seen something I've written.
And coming from the other side, from the younger,
hipper more internetty side is Brad Bell who
really created the show.
>>Brad Bell: Who uses the internet.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: So, that's what I do.
Yeah, I had an idea for a web series and thought,
there's something to that internet thing,
and when YouTube was first around in 2004,
2005 I think is when I became conscious of
it I was like, okay, wait, there's something
there.
There's a platform where there's no middle
man, this is brilliant.
I don't know what I'm gonna do with this but
I'm gonna do something.
And four or five years later we ended up making
"Husbands."
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah cause I'd seen the videos
that he'd made and put up on YouTube and they
were, the first one I saw was about marriage
equality and it was brilliant and funny and
I was like, I like the way this guy writes,
he tells jokes the way I tell jokes, we should
become friends.
And we did with no, I wasn't seeking someone
to do an online show with, it never occurred
to me to do an online show.
When you look at it from the TV side you sort
of feel like, well, I've got the biggest cameras
in the world and, like, what feels like the
biggest platform, why would I wanna do that?
Until someone points out to you that you're
not on the biggest platform.
>>Brad Bell: It's, yeah, I mean, there's this
perception that it's a smaller pond.
Like, oh your little small pond on the internet
and you can make the jump to the big boys
in TV but, I mean, really?
How many more millions of people can you reach
on the internet?
It's not a small pond it's an ocean.
>>Jane Espenson: Absolutely.
>>Brad Bell: It's the Indian Ocean and the
Arctic Ocean and the Atlantic Ocean and the
Pacific Ocean.
>>Jane Espenson: It's the Seven Seas.
>>Brad Bell: It's the Seven Seas.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah, so, it started occurring
to us, it didn't occur to us till we actually
had "Husbands" out there, actually, that that
we were in, we were in the big ocean.
That we could reach people internationally,
instantly, that there was sort of no ceiling
on the number of people we could reach.
We had perfect control over everything we
were doing for once which is also awesome.
But there was this sense that people kept
comparing it to broadcast.
If you look at the word broad in broadcast
it's just, oh it's so wide, worldwide web
has wide in it to.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: Like it's just it's a big
world.
>>Brad Bell: I think wide is probably broader
than broad.
>>Jane Espenson: I think.
>>Brad Bell: I mean I don't know for sure.
I just made it up.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: We'd have to get out a tape
measure.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: But you were talking about
the history, you looked up the history of
the word television, the original promise
of TV.
>>Brad Bell: It was because, you know when
somebody loves you or something you do but
they sort of insult you without realizing
it?
People would say things like, "Your show is
so good.
I wish it was a real show."
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: Or, "I don't get it its so funny,
why isn't it on TV?" and that didn't make
sense to me because it is on TV, I make television.
Like I don't know what a web series is, I
make television.
"Oh no, no, I mean like on that box in my
living room on Fox or AMC" and I didn't understand
what the distinction there was like what exactly
is it that defines television that I'm not
making television.
So, as it turns out, television is a hybrid
word, Greek and Latin, tele meaning far and
then vision meaning well, obviously, vision.
>>Jane Espenson: Vision.
>>Brad Bell: You know?
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: So, far vision, so when you think
of NBC the far vision is LA to New York.
>>Jane Espenson: Honolulu.
>>Brad Bell: Okay, Honolulu, too.
And maybe Guam.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: but anyways, it's not as
far as the worldwide web.
>>Brad Bell: Tokyo basically.
Yeah, on the other hand you plug something
into YouTube and within minutes, I mean, Tokyo
and all the other places that aren't in America.
>>Jane Espenson: Right.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: So the word television sounds
like it was meant to apply to the worldwide
web and when you actually go back and look
at how people talked about television when
it was a baby, that sounds like it's talking
about the worldwide web.
>>Brad Bell: And not just the original vision
of, oh vision of telev- I didn't even do that
on purpose.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: But the actual definition to
this day is telecommunication medium.
As anyone who's ever been in a relationship
knows, communication is a two way street.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: So a broadcast box where, you
know, they're, they're telling you what the
message is or telling you what the story is,
that's one sided and the internet is communication.
So, really, the internet is more television
than television.
>>Jane Espenson: It's the original promise
of television.
We put the name on the wrong box.
You're looking in the wrong box.
>>Brad Bell: For like 80 years.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah.
So television, we, we, television is being
invented now.
>>Brad Bell: Exactly cause it's just recently
been realized as such.
I mean, I think that technically speaking
it happened at the birth of the internet but
now it's almost an evolution in our own consciousness
of, oh wait, this is television.
>>Jane Espenson: We worked very hard to try
to make it match the quality of broadcast
television in terms of production quality
and, sort of, the process that went in to
the jokes and the performances and everything.
>>Brad Bell: Yes we want to match the production
quality and surpass the creative content and
quality of storytelling.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah and we started, you
might ask why doesn't network TV make content
that addresses issues like this or has, or
if you enjoyed it why doesn't network TV make
it?
It's so easy to say, "Oh it's cause they're
homophobic jerks" and it's like no they're
not, they're reasonable people who've been
taught a certain way of doing business and
they only have a certain amount of information
at their disposal to make decisions.
They end up with a couple assumptions.
I think that they assume that they can predict
how a show's gonna do via testing.
I once asked some executives, though, in a
meeting, I said, "Have you ever tested the
testing?
Have you ever gone back to see which shows
are successful and see if they actually were
the ones that were predicted to be successful?"
And they said yes they had done that, they
had crunched the numbers and there was a slight
negative correlation.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: And yet testing is still
used so they're clearly not getting the information
that they need to know about what to predict
what shows have an audience.
They also make this big assumption that the
cast of a show is gonna look like the audience
of that show.
So if they see a show with gay actors they're
gonna assume that they're only gonna get a
gay audience.
>>Brad Bell: Which is, sort of, I think been
brought about even more in the era of niche
and niche programming and everyone has their
own little channel that appeals to them-
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah, it's propagated this
assumption.
>>Brad Bell: Right because, you know, 30 years
ago there weren't those tiny little markets
so you could take a show that was specific
like the "Golden Girls" which is four women
in their 60's, like, yeah that sounds like
that has mass appeal, right?
Four single women in their 60's.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: We'll get the single women
in their 60's; they're not changing their
brands and stuff so?
>>Brad Bell: Yeah but I, just for fun, the
other day did a Twitter search on the "Golden
Girls" and I mean 5 minutes, 10 minutes, 15
minutes, 20 minutes, 25 minutes,
>>Jane Espenson: People making comments.
>>Brad Bell: No exaggeration, not one person
under, not one person over the age of 30,
they were all under 30 and loved the Golden
Girls, "Oh my gosh this is my favorite episode.
I always watch this before I leave the house."
I mean, 30 years later this show is still-
>>Jane Espenson: Drawing young people.
And if you, when I look back and think about
my viewing slate as a kid growing up in Central
Iowa in a very, sort of, homogenous part of
the country, my viewing slate was "What's
Happening" and "Sanford and Sons" and " The
Jeffersons" and I watched all of these shows
with a black cast and it never even occurred
to me that they weren't for me.
>>Brad Bell: Well, and those were massive
hits.
Today if you pitched a show with an all black
cast-
>>Jane Espenson: The assumption is that you'll
get a black audience.
>>Brad Bell: BET.
Go to BET that's a great place for your all
black show.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah, so I think networks
are now sometimes saying, "We can't afford
to be niche anymore because we'll only get
this one audience" when it's not the case.
>>Brad Bell: Well exactly and so what they
end up doing is making generic content as
opposed to universal content when, when you
really look at the history of what works most
effectively, you have very specific characters,
you have, you have a world that you can't
relate to and that's why you're interested
in watching it because you wanna learn something
from it and see what that's all about.
And by the end of that journey you realize
how much you do have in common, how much you
can relate and empathize.
>>Jane Espenson: And, of course, this has
become self fulfilling.
People know, oh I'm only supposed to watch
the content with the people look like me because
that's how it's being marketed to me and I
don't even see the ads for the things where
the characters all look like me.
And you end up with the situation that we
have now, where when I was a kid, black and
white audiences watched the same shows.
Now, other than Monday night football, I think
there is no overlap between the shows African
American audience members watch and white
audiences, it's like we have managed to split
it up but that doesn't have to be the case.
>>Brad Bell: Well I think that there was a
natural fragmentation with the internet and
with, you know, different choices of things
to watch but I think that it's being fed by
the other side as well because people are
going, "Oh, we want niche, okay let's make
it just for this audience."
And, you know, it's snowballing and both parties
I think are responsible, both the audience
and the creators.
>>Jane Espenson: And third, in case you forgot
we were counting on a list, the third and
final reason I think that network TV doesn't
make content like this is because the main
metric they have for measuring how well a
show is doing is pure ratings, just numbers,
households, not how engaged the people are
but just how many there are.
And this would be like we had someone make
an analogy to us once about, like, "Imagine
you're like a pork chop company and you've
got a Twitter site and you've got a million
followers but they're all vegetarians.
You're not selling your pork chops."
Like it doesn't matter what the numbers are
it matters whether you're reaching the right
people and it matters if they are engaged
in your product.
So, TV doesn't measure it that way.
So they're gonna look at a show like this-
>>Brad Bell: Absolutely.
>>Jane Espenson: and just see how many people
they can get not are those people who are,
as we discovered when we put this up on Kickstarter,
yeah, only a thousand donors.
A thousand donors who each pulled $60 out
of their wallet.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah and I mean we had someone
approach us recently and ask, "Well how many
views do you have?"
And I'm like, Are you living three years ago?
Like, how many views do we have, really?
600,000 the first season which is not an incredible
number.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah if you were a TV show-
>>Brad Bell: It's pretty good for 22 minutes
but it's not an incredible number.
So they we're like, oh you know, da, da, da
and I said, "But we raised $30,000 in 12 hours
if that makes a difference."
Yeah, if you've got a thousand people that
aren't buying your product and 100 people
that are buying three units of your product,
like, which do you want?
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah, so that's why TV doesn't
make content like this, is that they're not,
they're making these assumptions like, "Oh
it'll get a small number of people and it'll
only appeal to a niche and testing tells us
things that we know are wrong but we believe
anyway."
So there's all sorts of reasons why.
So, what's gonna happen to replace it?
The internet which is fantastic unless internet
ends up making the same mistakes TV did.
There's this temptation to go, "Oh, how did
TV get to be what it is?
Let's do that same thing" and you end up just
copying all the bugs from the old software
into the new software.
>>Brad Bell: Or on the other end of the spectrum,
trying to completely reinvent the wheel and,
oh this new machine with this interface and
it's all about how we, you know, put the content
in front of the viewer and how we tag it and
how we get them to click on the next thing
and no, it's not really, it's just about making
great content.
I mean, our engagement is 100 percent.
People sit and watch our content.
Like when I hear other, other content creators
saying, you know, "This ADD thing, people
are just clicking off and they don't wanna
watch and we really just don't know how to
wrangle it, you know, cause people are just
ADD now and that's all there is to it."
Making all these excuses and I don't know
how many of you have been in sales or seen
Glenngary Glenn Ross
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: But it's not the leads, you know
what I mean?
Sell it, like don't blame the leads.
You either sell something or you don't.
>>Jane Espenson: Well kids are sitting there
playing video games till they fall over.
>>Brad Bell: They die.
That's, I mean-
>>Jane Espenson: That's an engaged audience.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: That's an engaged audience.
>>Jane Espenson: We should be, how can we
achieve?
>>Brad Bell: How can we kill our audience?
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: But I think that the argument
to that is that it's active and, you know,
viewing is passive but I disagree.
When you are integrated with an audience that
is passionate about a show, look at "Mad Men"
parties.
People gathering at their houses, dressing
in period costumes, making drinks and watching
"Mad Men," it's social.
Like, you don't need a technical interface
to be social, TV has always been social.
You know, the birth of Little Ricky, seventy
percent of Americans with a television were
watching the birth of Little Ricky all at
the same time.
>>Jane Espenson: And TV has, because TV is,
network TV, traditional TV has gotten so chopped
up it isn't really about building community
and that 70 percent of the way people are
watching anymore, the internet is about building
community.
So if you take that building communities thing
that the internet does really well and you
take the emotional engagement that scripted
entertainment-
>>Brad Bell: Exactly.
>>Jane Espenson: does better than any other
form of entertainment where people are, they
are hanging on the birth of Little Ricky because
it is novelistic, the script, you're waiting
to see what the writers have come up with.
That same passion that people have for "Husbands"
of waiting, it kills them that they wait two
weeks between the episodes cause they can't
wait to see what's gonna happen.
They are pulled in.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah, exactly and I think that
that is, the crucial element is the emotional
attachment which, incidentally, I mean if
you wanna talk revenue, is also the first
step toward making your audience more receptive
to being sold because they're already emotionally
invested in what they're watching and you
buy things emotionally.
So if you're emotionally giving yourself already
when you're being advertised, too, then there's
already an emotional bond there that it makes
you a little more inclined to trust the people
putting that product in front of you.
>>Jane Espenson: Usually it's cause an initial
like this, the things that you see Cheeks
and Brady using design a lifestyle, a place,
a hip place, hip people and sort of an aspirational
lifestyle.
So we had a fan in season one who tracked
down the hotel robe that Cheeks was wearing
in a scene.
>>Brad Bell: This hotel was not publicly named.
>>Jane Espenson: Right she had to figure it
out.
>>Brad Bell: She had to figure out what this
hotel was, contact them, purchase this, and
she lives in New Zealand
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: purchase this robe for over $100
and this is like a 19 year old university
student.
We're not talking like some, some eccentric,
wealthy person who has the means and the time,
without advertising it at all.
In fact, there's a green necklace that I wear
in the scene where I'm talking to Haley in
the kitchen, Tweeted a picture of it, just
tweeted a picture and said "Day 2 on the set."
And immediately the response was "Where can
I get that necklace?
Oh my God, I want that necklace."
And that is because of an emotional attachment
to the character.
It's the Rachel haircut, the Rachel haircut
from "Friends" was iconic and getting that
haircut meant that you were a fun single girl
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: And everyone loved you and you
lit up the room, that is the connection that
people want to their programming.
>>Jane Espenson: A lot of people are gonna
be getting the Brady.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah, I think so.
The Brady buzz cut.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: That is what we strive for.
We strive to entertain people in that way
and give people that connection because there
is an audience out there that has been largely
abandoned by networks and cable that used
to love TV.
I mean, cord cutter is a term now because
the internet has better things to offer and
TV doesn't and there are a lot of people that
are hungry and wandering around saying, "Where
is it?
Where's the good stuff?
What happened to must see TV?"
>>Jane Espenson: Right.
This is reinventing television or inventing
television, inventing must see TV all over
again.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah, so that sense of community
that you get when you watch television on
the internet combined with the fantastic programming
that television, in its heyday, offered.
>>Jane Espenson: So that's our vision of the
future.
That's how we think "Husbands" is inventing
television and I don't know, are you ready
for Q&A?
>>Brad Bell: Yeah.
>>Jane Espenson: You wanna hear what the people
have to say.
>>Brad Bell: I would love to know, yeah exactly,
what the feedback is from-
>>Jane Espenson: Either the thoughts or the
show or really anything.
We're happy to answer any questions.
[Pause]
>>Brad Bell: Particularly because you're professionals
in this arena.
>>female #1: I only watched the show for the
first time like a few days ago when I heard
that the talk was gonna be here and, because
I love "Firefly" and things like that I have
>>Jane Espenson: Oh, thank you.
>>female #1: I had to come to the talk.
So I watched the show and I sat down there
and I thought, "Okay, I'll watch an episode"
but I didn't realize it was only like two
or three minutes an episode.
>>Jane Espenson: Oh, season one?
>>female #1: Yeah, season one, so I started
watching it and I was like, "Oh, okay, I can
watch the whole season in the time it takes
me to normally watch an episode" which is
cool I could catch up on season one quickly
but I'm wondering about the format.
I mean, I, it's so good but I can't sit there
and just like get into it.
I can't, you know, I can't do a marathon of
"Husbands"
>>Jane Espenson: That's how things changed
between season one and season two.
These, you saw, were much longer, these were
ten minute episodes.
>>female #1: Yeah actually I hadn't realized
how much time they were taking but they felt
like they went deeper.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah.
>>female #1: So is this just because you're
trying it out?
Is this what you think episodes should be
like?
Can you talk more about the format?
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah, we think people are
feeling what you're feeling.
>>Brad Bell: Well, yeah, there are a few reasons,
I mean, I think a year ago short form worked
better but I think that's how quickly the
internet evolves.
People are watching content longer and we
are making television and television has traditionally
been a structured format of a half hour or
an hour and, you know, if we had the budget
we would certainly release 24-30 minute episodes
at a time.
Since that's not really what we're doing right
now we thought that the best way to split
it up would be in three acts because, you
know, a sitcom has three acts and, yeah, it
does, it allows you to spend more time with
the characters and really get into the world.
Yeah, and, we have more hits on our 10 minute
episode than we had on our, at this point,
than we had at this point on our first 2 minute
episode.
>>Jane Espenson: Which is amazing for people
to sit for 10 minutes, like, it really has
changed.
People are starting to feel that what you're
feeling like, I wanna settle in like it's
a TV show.
>>Brad Bell: It is a TV show.
>>Jane Espenson: It's a TV show.
>>Brad Bell: So they're wondering where the
rest is and they're still complaining it's
too short at 10 minutes.
"I want more, it's too short!"
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah, people have that 22-24
minute programmed into our DNA from all the
years of watching TV and ideally we would
hope to be able to make enough "Husbands"
that we could make a whole series of full
length 24 minute episodes.
Right now we can make one chunk of content
like that and we wanna, you know, you work
for many, many months to premier it all and
have it all blown out in a day would be a
shame.
>>Brad Bell: Right, well, interestingly enough,
you know, we talk in these terms of, "Well
if we had the budget" that doesn't even mean
a network budget.
I mean, we make an episode, a half hour episode
of "Husbands" for half of what one "Modern
Family" cast member gets paid.
To put it into perspective.
That would be our version of a big budget.
>>Jane Espenson: The third executive producer
on the show is Jeff Greenstein who directed
the episodes and he's fantastic and he always
says, he writes for "Desperate Housewives"
and he always says that we make this show
for the bottled water budget on "Desperate
Housewives."
[Laughter]
>>female #1: Have you thought about trying
to get a way for those 600,000 viewers or
whatever you had to contribute?
I mean, I also didn't know about your Kickstarter
thing.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah, that's exactly how we made
season 2.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah we raised, we asked
for $50,000 they gave us $60,000.
So that, yeah, that paid for season 2 with
a little help but, yeah, I mean that if we
wanna make more that is one of the options
to stick up, to go back and say, keep taking
a look, you got more, you got anything else
in there?
[Laughter]
>>female #1: I mean, if all those "Firefly"
fans could have paid to have you write more
episodes I'm sure they would have, right?
>>Jane Espenson: I'm sure that's right.
I think, my first instinct with the Kickstarter
was to feel a little ooky about, like, gee
I'm asking people, I don't know what their
means are and I'm asking them for money to
make a thing.
And I sort of realized they, they're, it's
not a donation, it's a purchase.
They are buying this content because they
really, really want it.
>>female #1: Yeah, Starbucks doesn't have
any problem asking for the money for the lattes,
right?
>>Brad Bell: Exactly.
It's like buying a ticket to a movie, you
know, or yeah, renting it.
I mean, you're supporting it.
The more people that buy the ticket to the
first one there might be a sequel and maybe
it'll be good.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah it's when we, like the
$50 incentive for the Kick starter was the
DVD and you start going, "We're charging $50
for a DVD, oh my God!"
Then you go, no we're not.
We're allowing them to buy more product and
here's the DVD we think you might like.
>>Brad Bell: Well, and we were also simultaneously
able to offer them more content without expanding
the budget because we had behind the scenes
crew.
So we have a documentary that's four, yeah
four installments at ten minutes apiece and,
I mean, it's edited like a show.
It's entertaining and shows the highlights
and the relationships and what went on backstage
and the whole process.
>>Jane Espenson: So between every week, every
Wednesday they'll be a new episode or a new
behind the scenes which shows you the making
of the previous episode.
So you can become a scholar of "Husband."
[Laughter]
>>female #1: I like the cameos, too.
That's great.
Nathan Fillion in the second season.
>>Jane Espenson: Nathan Fillion in season
1 and season 2, yeah, I don't know if you
all recognize Josh Whedon and Mekhi Phifer
and Clare Grant were all in this, and John
Hodgman and Jon Cryer.
Yeah, Jon Cryer, oh my God, a star of that
caliber, that was amazing.
>>male #1: You have a lot to say about how
networks screen and choose their programming.
Do you see a future where instead of improving
that, networks just pick up shows that have
started and proven that they have an audience
through, you know, internet mediums such as
yours?
>>Jane Espenson: There's been some of that,
yeah.
>>Brad Bell: They've done that.
>>Jane Espenson: Web therapy, Children's Hospital,
there's been a couple shows like that.
Yeah.
But then you start just thinking of yourself
as being in the developmental ball park of
the baseball system and it's, it's, it gets
in that same mindset of like well you're the
little pond.
>>Brad Bell: Exactly.
Exactly, it doesn't, it's fishing something
out of the ocean and putting it in a barrel.
And the perception right now is "Oh, you made
the jump to TV" like TV is the king.
Well that broadcast thing is not actually
TV.
The web is TV as we've established.
>>male #1: I guess I'll take your answers
that you think content creators in your position
shouldn't shoot for the networks as a sign
of success.
>>Jane Espenson: Exactly.
>>male #1: Although I still have the question,
do you think that networks will continue to
reach down and pull in, pull in content-
>>Brad Bell: Throughout the net and pull up
all the-
>>male #1: Yeah, rather than develop their
own shows.
I'm thinking if I'm a network executive why
should I risk, you know, I don't know how
many 10's of millions of dollars to watch
a show, instead I could buy something, buy
the rights to something that's proven to have
a content and, you know?
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah I think they will.
I think it's a little tricky because they
look at viewing numbers, like we're saying,
instead of engagement so it's not really of
the metrics to know what to pull out.
But I love this analogy, it's like they're
lying to lobsters, we've been lying to lobsters
for years.
You've graduated from the ocean to this swanky
tank in this fancy restaurant.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: That's exactly; oh my God I wanna
see a cartoon.
[Laughter]
>>male #2: If I may, I don't wanna be picky
but it's, I mean, when I hear the word content
and I think of some product sold in a box
or something in a jar.
I mean, I think it kind of disparages your
work, I mean, why not call it a great show
or something like that.
I just heard so many times, content, every
time I felt, eeh?
>>Jane Espenson: Well no, you're right.
>>Brad Bell: What word would you rather us
use?
>>male #2: I don’t know, I mean it's a show,
it's a nice show, it's a great story.
>>Brad Bell: Isn't it amazing, though, that
it can be a commercial product and a great
show with an artistic message with real emotion
and characters?
>>male #2: Even mention it's an awesome commercial
product but I mean, content, it's just so
low, I think.
>>Jane Espenson: I know what you mean because
it equates the same, it's, "Oh, 10 minutes
of programming" as if you're squeezing toothpaste
out of a tube and that's, it's the content
of, I get what he's saying.
And the metaphor suggests that it's not the,
it's not the quality of the toothpaste it's
the amount.
But we don't have a better word right now.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah, well, okay.
I don't think content is a bad word I think
that content gets a bad rap because there's
not a lot of good content.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: But, I mean, yes, this is show
business not show art and we are interested
in both the creative and the social statement
and doing something good and being entertaining
and all of that comes first but we certainly
never forget that it has to be a commercial
product and that it has to be content offered
in a way that earns revenue.
>>Jane Espenson: I hear you.
Actually the social good is a thing that we
wanted to mention that we forgot to mention
which is like one of the things we love about
the show is that it isn't just good and entertaining,
we actually think it does, it does good for
the world which is another way that it feels
like it is a right to associate it with the
internet where people have that kind of global
reach and influence.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah.
>>male #3: This is a question about the writing
that you went through for this.
You clearly, you talked about how you feel
like the 22, 24 minutes kind of engrained
into people, and you clearly, you couldn't,
you didn't do that, you only had like the
10 minute episodes but you were telling that
kind of 24 minuteish story.
How did you approach that in the attempt to
not recreate the wheel but still take the
good things from the way TV does it?
Like, was that different from other shows
you've written?
>>Jane Espenson: Actually, half hour shows
usually are written in three acts about 8
minutes each.
So we were doing exactly what TV does.
>>male #3: You didn't make any changes for
the fact that you knew that there'd be a large
chunk of time between each of the acts.
>>Jane Espenson: No we didn't particularly
bother to reset it or anything.
We knew people would be able to go back and
watch their way into it.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah because, exactly, on the
screen the other videos, the other episode
is right there if you've missed anything or-
>>Jane Espenson: We want it to feel as much
like traditional, what people are used to,
as possible and time tested formula.
>>Brad Bell: But, yeah, it is television so
we made television.
It's annoying.
>>Jane Espenson: But you know what we could
do, we could swear.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: That's true.
Well and that's the really cool thing is that
it is television without boundary.
>>Jane Espenson: Right.
>>Brad Bell: At all.
>>Jane Espenson: We could have that bedroom
scene which was not particularly anything
beyond what you could see on any sort of sex
scene in a-
>>Brad Bell: Oh easily, soap opera.
One o'clock in the afternoon, children could
be watching.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: But we did feel this great
freedom to show something that other places
might have blanched at, blanched and fallen
out of their chairs.
>>male #4: I love the writing sprints.
I think that's very cool.
A lot of Google code has been written during
writing sprints.
>>Jane Espenson: Really?
>>male #4: Yeah.
>>Jane Espenson: Oh my God.
>>male #4: For real.
And I just wanted to ask you to talk a little
bit about how because the internet is a much
more bidirectional medium and there's, like,
a channel coming back from the fans, like,
what made you decide to, like, invite people,
like, "No, you be creative, too."
>>Jane Espenson: Right.
It was totally, I totally backed into it.
I was like, "Geeze I need to write and I'm
sitting here on Twitter and I'm just getting
pulled into it.
I’m having too much fun and I'm not gonna
write unless I just promise myself I'm gonna
write.
Oh hey, I can promise Twitter I'm gonna write."
So it was just I'm gonna write in 20 minutes,
and then almost as an afterthought I put in
like, "Why don't you do it too?"
And people loved, everybody would come back
at the end of the hour and say, "I finished
my dissertation, I'm gonna write a novel."
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: "I started that screen play
I haven't dusted off in 10 years" like suddenly
people were getting all this stuff done and
I realized, okay, this isn't just good for
me but it's helping people get stuff done,
it's that community building and now they're
sort of like a regular group of people when
I announce a writing sprint.
I don't know what they're doing that they're
able to drop everything but there's just this
whole flock of them that every time I announce
it it's like, "I'm in!" and they write or
clean their kitchen or code or edit or something
for that hour and it's wonderful and it's,
and so many people come up to me and thank
me for them and it's really made me realize
the power I didn't know that was out there.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah, that's the thing about
getting people to go out there and galvanize
and really do something in real life.
>>Jane Espenson: And I love your shirt, you're
wearing your marriage equality, gay rights
Google shirt.
Woo!
Nice.
Yeah, we've actually been gifted with those
shirts already, we love them very much.
>>male #5: We have a question from the VC
from another office.
This is a question from Rob Borner.
He says, "I was intrigued by the comment Cheeks
makes in the Return of the Zebra that he has
an exotic femininity in a society that views
that as weakness.
Could you expand on that and say if one of
the goals of the show is to combat that social
stigma?"
>>Brad Bell: Combat is not a word I would
use.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: Appropriate is not the word.
>>Brad Bell: But yes, comment on it, certainly
I think that yes.
Masculine means you are strong and you are
a provider and you can kill, roar.
Feminine means, oh you're helpless and oh
goodness and I think particularly ditzy and
aloof and you can't be all that serious and
you can't be all that intelligent.
So yes, part of the character of Cheeks and
part of the message, "message" I don't like
that word, of the show is that femininity
is strength and there is power there and there
is intelligence there and-
>>Jane Espenson: It's not a bad word.
>>Brad Bell: It's not a bad word, yeah, and
people say, yeah cause I get that like, "You're
a little more, no, you tend to be a little
more feminine."
What?
Like that was gonna offend me?
Like, I know.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: I like that.
>>Brad Bell: You know, and the whole notion
of like, well why doesn't he just dress like
a woman or why doesn't he just be a girl if
he wants to be a girl?
I don't.
I like being a guy.
I like all the things about being a guy.
I love peeing standing up.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: So jealous.
>>Brad Bell: I mean, being a dude is so much
easier than being a chick.
You could not pay me.
But I love femininity and I, you know, I don't,
it's just not, why look down on it?
I don't understand why our society does that,
this hyper masculinization thing.
>>Jane Espenson: And you're saying something
in episode we just watched about owning your
stereotype, owning a stereotype, not being
afraid of it.
>>Brad Bell: If it's authentic to you.
>>Jane Espenson: Right.
>>Brad Bell: Like there's a difference between
adopting an identity that you feel is built
on a legacy of, yeah, stereotypes that have
come before you that you need to have to belong
to a community.
That's totally different.
What I'm saying is I love Madonna.
I have always loved Madonna.
I mean, not so much lately she's getting kind
of out of control.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: But I mean, yeah, I was six years
old and I was like voguing my face off.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: I just, like, what am I supposed
to butch it up so that people take me more
seriously?
Or because I represent every gay man in the
world, it doesn't make sense.
You know, so.
>>Jane Espenson: What I love is that by using
the word femininity, you aren't just defending
men you're defending all of womanhood, too.
You're pointing out the history of femininity,
femaleness and saying this has gotten a bad
rap the whole time.
>>Brad Bell: Right.
Well, I think that every human being has masculine
and feminine qualities.
Last night I drilled screws into the tile
so that I could hang a clock.
>>Jane Espenson: Awesome.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: And my friend said, "You're so
butch sometimes."
And, you know, then I opened a jar of pickles
for her.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: But we all have masculine and
feminine traits so I don't see any reason
to be afraid of them or ashamed of them or
to play them down or to deny that they're
there because we're afraid of how it, how
it might reflect on us.
>>Jane Espenson: But then as soon as you tap
into one of the very few negative comments
that we ever get on the show which is like,
"Oh a stereotype" and it's like, if people
watch the show carefully they'll see that
that, we're saying something about stereotype.
>>Brad Bell: Well, yeah, exactly and you have
to start someplace in order to have an arc
and I did see an interesting comment about
this most recent episode that said, "You know,
if a girl were doing this like Lucy or Dharma,
it would be endearing but on a guy it's just
annoying."
And I thought, "Well there's a whole new conversation."
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: Why is Lucy endearing but a man
is anno- a man is bratty, a man isn't thinking
about other people when he does it, like,
what's with that double standard?
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah.
I saw a comment that called Cheeks an airhead,
the character Cheeks and it's like if you
watch more than a minute of our show you'll
see that he's the smart one.
>>Brad Bell: And to me that's the person that's
listening to the tone of voice who's seeing
the mannerisms, like, I could be saying some
really intelligent thesis but, like, if I'm
saying it like this
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: You're just looking at this;
you're listening to the words I'm saying.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: And that's kind of my point.
>>male #6: If I may ask a second question
actually trying to build on that, still I
think there's still society has kind of a
problem when straight men have a feminine
side.
I think, it's still not acceptable, I mean,
I personally have that problem a lot and it
seems like people look at you in a weird way.
So, I mean, I don't think it's just a problem
that gay men have, it's just-
>>Brad Bell: I completely agree.
I think that men need a revolution which sounds
ridiculous because men run the world.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: And make more money than women,
I mean, it's true.
So like why do men need a revolution?
Well, because there are, there are so many
different interpretations of what a woman
can be.
You can be a ballerina or you can be a truck
driver, you know, girl power, girls can do
anything.
That's a message that's promoted a lot.
Now it's not always executed very well but
there is that idea in society and a man has
to be one very specific model of what a heterosexual
man acts like and if he doesn't act that way
somethings, he's gay or, you know, there's
something going on there.
So, yes, I absolutely think men need a revolution
to say, like, and I think it's probably men's
fault, too, I think men probably play into
it.
They don't want to go outside the box, they're
afraid of being judged like every human being
and they don't want to seem yeah, like any
way they might come across, any possible perception
that might exist if they step a toe over that
line.
>>Jane Espenson: So much of this is so engrained,
of all the different things we're talking
about.
I was just thinking about you've got fine
china but you wanna imply this isn't, this
isn't fine china this is almost like a parody,
this is low quality fine china, this is the
paper plate version of fine china, chinette.
We'll put the feminine ending on it so to
me [cannot understand] and it's like stuff
gets engrained that tight in our language
so it's, it's gonna take, it's gonna take
a show like "Husbands" to fix it.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: Well, I mean, yeah.
I think that, I have this story that I like,
it's sort of a parable about starfish and
there's two guys walking on the beach and
there's one of them throwing starfish back
into the ocean-
>>Jane Espenson: Cause they're all washed
up and drowning.
>>Brad Bell: Yeah there's like, you know-
>>Jane Espenson: Suffering.
>>Brad Bell: If you've ever seen starfish
beached and then they die, so he's throwing,
one by one, these starfish back into the ocean
and the other guy says, "Why are you doing
that?
You can't save all of them.
Like, what does it matter?" and the other
guys says, "Well, it matters to that one.
It matters to that one."
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: "And it matters to that one."
So, yes, that is what we're trying to do with
"Husbands" and just because, you know, everyone
in the world doesn't know what "Husbands"
is, is no reason not to try and go with that
change.
>>Jane Espenson: Reprogram.
Reach every starfish with a computer.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: Yeah.
>>Jane Espenson: That's our goal.
>>Brad Bell: Exactly.
>>Jane Espenson: Wow, that went fast.
>>Brad Bell: I mean, if there's anyone else
we're happy.
>>Jane Espenson: Oh yeah we're.
[Pause]
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah you can get poster advertising
the talk signed by both of us.
>>Brad Bell: I didn't know we had posters.
>>Jane Espenson: We have posters.
Dude, we're big time.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: Well I have 8x10's of me and
Brady in our underwear if you want those.
[Laughter]
>>Brad Bell: No I really do if you want them,
they're pretty.
>>Jane Espenson: Yeah we have season 2 promo
pictures.
So, I think that concludes our official talk
now it's just all underpants pictures for
the rest of the time.
[Laughter]
>>Jane Espenson: So come on up and say hi.
[Applause]
>>Brad Bell: Thank you.
>>Jane Espenson: Thank you.